good morning hi it's Tuesday every year
I do a holiday book Roundup to recommend
books that you can give in the holiday
season this year I'm also including
three non- gifts but we're going to
start with the books do you know
somebody who's a bit of a Doomer and
feels hopeless all the time and like the
world is in a state of collapse I do
well I recommend that they read this
book not the end of the world by Hannah
Richie from our world and data I love
Hannah Richie I love our world in data
and I love this book I just emerged from
it feeling hopeful which you know the
hyp priced commodity these days my
favorite novel of the year was Rebecca
maai I have some questions for you which
is crimey and podcasty but also just
brilliant Rebecca McKai writes some of
the best sentences around and it's very
rare that I read a work of fiction and
turn to Sarah and say why can't I write
like this but several times while
reading this book I turned to Sarah and
said why can't I write like this my
favorite tuberculosis book of the year
and yes I have a favorite tuberculosis
book of the year is the Black Angels by
Maria smos this is a great great gift
for anybody who's interested in history
it's all about these black nurses
working in Staten Island many of whom
were from the American South who helped
cure tuberculosis it's just an
incredible Story one of those where
you're like I can't believe this has
never been told before but also the
writing is phenomenal what's our first
of three non-book recommendations why
it's Hank's cancer socks these really
are great socks and nobody's paying me
to say that because I'm an unpaid intern
the designs are so good and they're
super comfortable plus 100% of the
profit goes to expand access to Cancer
Care around the world and it's looking
like that's going to be several hundred,
how does Hank do it every time all right
on to funny stuff you know how sometimes
there are celebrity Memoirs and you read
them and you're like I mean I'm pretty
sure that was Ghost written and then
other times you read a celebrity Memoir
and you're like man Matthew mccon wrote
that uh Lesley Jones wrote this and it's
great if you're interested in music and
especially like the history of rock and
roll I really recommend this boy by my
mentor Eileen Cooper oh my God John
lennin had a child childhood it's all
about the childhoods of John Lennon and
Paul McCartney and it's amazing it's a
children's book so like you can
recommend it to the kids in your life
but also I just loved it one of my big
life hacks actually is that when you're
getting interested in a subject or you
want to really learn about something
read the kids book Like Walter Dean
Meers book about the Haitian revolution
or this book about tuberculosis like
they answer all the questions that like
the grown-up history books assume that
you already know all right a
recommendation for the person in your
life who really loves getting clean
which should be you know most of the
people in your life we've got this
beautiful vidiian sun bath box it's from
sunbase and soap our Soap Company so I
designed this to create the perfect bath
box it's got this beautiful hearside
candle made in the Pacific Northwest
it's got my three favorite Sun Basin
soaps my favorite bath bomb in the world
some bath salt it's it's real good and
we also have some smaller boxes of soap
and stuff it's just a great present soap
because it's something that people will
actually use you have somebody in your
life who's like really into business or
unlocking their professional potential
or whatever because I loved this book
hidden potential by Adam Grant like this
is not the kind of book I usually like
but it really helped me understand that
a lot of what I think of as my inability
or ineptitude might be constructed and
not really real and that's had a pretty
profound impact both in my relationship
to business and in terms of what I think
I can write and lastly in the book
category for any science Andor animal
nerds in your life an immense World by
Ed yangong
wow this book really radically deepened
my appreciation for and understanding of
nonhuman animals if you have a coffee
lover in your life awesome coffee is
here to support all of your gifting
needs with our awesome coffee gift boxes
all right Hank hopefully I've sorted
100% of your holiday shopping I will see
you on
Friday oh I didn't tell you what I
wanted I want this I have one of them
but I want another one of them so that's
what I want I don't want to be hyper
specific and prescriptive in my gift
requests but I want this Hank this
vidiian sun bath box sent to my house
wrapped by you on Christmas Day